okay
thank you for coming today
last night in conjunction with the
Pennsylvania State Police
the Federal Bureau of Investigation
detectives arrested 28 year old Brian
Christopher coburger in albrightsville
Pennsylvania
on a warrant for murders of Ethan
Zena
Madison
and Kaylee
I want to personally thank these
agencies for their assistance in this
case
coburger resides in Pullman Washington
and is a graduate student at Washington
State University
we will provide as much information as
we can about the extra addition to Idaho
and the criminal process however due to
Idaho state law we are limited in what
information we can release today and
tell Cole Burger has been has his
initial appearance in Idaho Court
I want to express my appreciation to our
local community
the people of Idaho and those throughout
our nation Who provided information
to help us investigate these murders has
been very impressive we've received over
19
000 tips and we've conducted over 300
interviews
to recap this case
on the evening of November 12th Kaylee
and Madison arrived home at about 1 56
a.m after visiting a local bar and
street food vendor
Ethan Zanna we're at the sigma Kai house
before arriving home around 1 45 A.M
the two surviving roommates had also
been in the community but returned
around 1am
on the morning of November 13th
a 9-1-1 call was made at 11 58 A.M
reporting an unconscious person at the
residence
the call came in call came from inside
the home from one of the surviving
roommates cell phones
Moscow police responded and found two
victims on the second floor
and two victims on the third floor
on November 17th autopsies were
conducted in the late talk County
coroner confirmed the identity of the
four victims
the cause and manner of death was
homicide by stabbing
some had defensive wounds and each had
multiple
um each had been stabbed multiple times
these murders have shaken our community
and no arrest will ever bring back these
young students
however
we do believe Justice will be found
through the criminal process
this was a very complex and extensive
case
we had developed a clear picture over
time
and we stand assured that the work
was not the work is not done but be
assured the work is not done this has
just started
since November we have remained laser
focused on pursuing pursuing every lead
in our pursuit of justice for the
victims and their families
I recognize the frustration with the
lack of information that's been released
however providing any details in this
criminal investigation might obtain it
the upcoming criminal prosecution or
alerted the suspect of our progress
we will continue to provide as much
information as we can as a process moves
forward
today I want to specifically thank our
dedicated Moscow Police Department
Detectives
Patrol officers
the Idaho State detectives the Idaho
state troopers and their crime lab
technicians and scientists and the
Federal Bureau of Investigation for the
resources and Personnel to conduct this
massive investigation
it was the dedication of them and the
persistence and the numerous hours
that led to an arrest
fortunately
these highly skilled people work
together as a cohesive team to solve
this case
I also want to thank our community
and the nation
over the past six weeks I've been
continually reminded of how much our
community cares
locally public support has been
exceptional with kind words food for
investigators
and letters of support
you will never know how much your words
of encouragement help us through these
trying times
I appreciate I appreciate each of you in
each of your kindness
agencies and individuals from Across the
Nation have reached out to us
to express their support to this
department
I'm reminded our Moscow Community our
families and the nation has been
impacted by this daily
finally I do want to thank our Media
Partners for the help you kept this in
the news
you helped us with tips you kept things
going and we truly appreciate that and
you are the product of those 19
000 tips that we received which is
impressive number
I would like to uh invite Bill Thompson
the County prosecutor up at this time
good afternoon folks my name is Bill
Thompson I'm the only talk County
prosecutor
and it's sad to be here but happy to be
here at the same time
as Chief fry indicated
um a criminal complaint was filed
yesterday here in Lata County
charging the defendant Mr kohlberger
with four counts first degree murder
in addition to felony burglary which
involves entering the residence with the
intent to commit the crime of murder
Mr kohlberger
and let me preface there is a pending
case now in court and
I in my office and the investigators
have to live with the restrictions that
our Supreme Court places on pre-trial
publicity
that said I promise you we will share
with you
through the court process or otherwise
whatever we are allowed to I just
appreciate your patience on that
the factual basis for the charges are
summarized in what's called a probable
cause affidavit that is on file with the
court
according to the rules of the United
Supreme Court that is sealed until Mr
kohlberger is physically back in Layton
County and has been served with the
Idaho arrest warrant
at that time we expect that that
affidavit will be available to you so
you can share the true facts with all of
your readers and your Watchers and your
listeners and all the people who are
interested and really need to know
what's going on so please have patience
with us on that we hope to get that to
you as soon as we can
as far as Mr kohlberger I can share with
you that he is a graduate student
Washington State University and has an
apartment residence over at Pullman
he has had an initial appearance in
front of a judge in Pennsylvania he's
being held without bond and a warrant
from our Magistrate Judge here also
provides for no bond
we understand that he's scheduled to be
back in court in Pennsylvania next
Tuesday afternoon
and that a public defender has been
appointed for him there
process at this point is since he was
arrested in another state he has the
opportunity to either waive extradition
and return voluntarily to the state of
Idaho or if he prefers not to wave
extradition then we will initiate
extradition proceedings through our
governor's office
if we do that it can take a while for
him to get here so again I'm asking for
your patience and understand that's just
the way the system works
once he gets here
he'll have an initial appearance with
our magistrate they'll deal with issues
such as making sure council is competent
council is representing him and the case
will be scheduled for further hearings
your primary source of factual
information is going to be the court
record because that's what the Supreme
Court says we need to refer you to so
please pay attention to what's going on
in court and have people there to watch
and hear what's being said as as an
attorney myself in my office we are
limited on what we are allowed by the
courts to say outside of the courtroom
so please just work with us
finally as the chief indicated
this is not the end of this
investigation in fact this is a new
beginning
you all now know the name of the person
who's been charged with these offenses
please get that information out there
please ask the public anyone who knows
about this individual to come forward
call the tip line report anything you
know about him to help the investigators
and eventually our office and the court
system understand fully everything there
is to know about not only the individual
but what happened and why
next I'll introduce Colonel Ted Wells
from the Idaho State Police thank you
well good afternoon my name is Kedrick
Wills I serve as the Director of the
Idaho State Police and certainly want to
express our appreciation for your
attendance here today
these tragic murders took four young
vibrant lives from our community
nothing we do can bring them back
the only thing that we can do in law
enforcement to honor their memories that
we know of is to bring this to a
successful conclusion
this has been a very difficult time for
the families
the University
the community and the state of Idaho
however it is also proven that
communities come together in tough times
certainly appreciate the support of the
local community and our national
audience that has been following us as
we've worked our investigators have
worked through this case
I'm thankful also to you the Media
Partners who have helped keep this case
in the Forefront that generates the tips
and continues will we hope will continue
to generate information that will help
us to a conclusion of this proceeding
I'd like to express our appreciation on
behalf of the Idaho State Police to
Chief Frye
his leadership and the entire Moscow
Police Department for the way that they
handled this from the very beginning
he directed the right people to the
right right positions that led us to
this conclusion today
I've had the utmost confidence in this
investigation and in Chief fry as well
as in Mr Bill Thompson and the Layton
County prosecutor's office who've been a
great partner throughout this
nothing has deterred the commitment of
the investigators who've worked on this
case regardless of the organization they
represent it's been very trying and very
difficult as we know as you know that it
has been on those investigators as they
do the tedious work that they're so good
at doing
the Partnerships is What's led here as
well the Partnerships between Moscow
Police Department the I'd like to
express our appreciation with the
Federal Bureau of Investigation
specifically the special agent in charge
out of the Salt Lake City division
Dennis rice and also what the work that
happened in the last 24 hours in in
Pennsylvania with the arrest with the
Pennsylvania State Police and Colonel
evanchik with the Pennsylvania State
Police we appreciate what they've done
Across the Nation to help us as well
as Bill shared this investigation is far
from over
in fact I appreciate what he shared that
this is not an ending but rather a new
beginning the difference now is as he
shared that we are dictated what
information we can share by the court
process and by laws in our state of
Idaho and so we will share as he shared
Mr Thompson's is absolutely committed to
share everything he can share through
the court process we've got to make sure
that we don't get in front of that
process and we really appreciate deeply
appreciate everybody's support here the
relationships that were forged here and
the Partnerships that were Fords have
led to this and based on that is why
we're here today and we continue to
believe that the best way we can honor
these four lives that have been taken is
to make sure that we have a successful
outcome here one of the Partnerships
that's been forged throughout this is a
partnership with the University of Idaho
and on that I'd like to introduce the
president of the University of Idaho Mr
Scott Greene
thank you good afternoon Scott Greene
president University of Idaho
today's news and arrests is a welcome
one
it's relief to our University our
community and our extended Vandal family
the outpouring of Support over the past
six weeks helps sustain us during the
most trying time
they provided the strength that helped
us navigate the international scrutiny
visited them our students and employees
we are truly thankful for the compassion
and acts of kindness shown to our
community
kindness is contagious and it provided
the light that reclaimed ground lost to
evil and darkness
we first want to acknowledge and thank
Governor little for the early promise of
financial support that enabled the
university to secure our campus and
focus on helping our students and our
employees in the wake of the crimes
we also appreciate the Idaho State
Police and the highly visible security
presence that brought comfort and calm
to a community shocked and confused by
the senseless crimes
we never lost faith that this case would
be solved and are grateful for the hard
work of the Moscow police department and
their law enforcement partners
vast and committed FBI resources brought
important expertise to this complex case
across the board dedicated highly
competent Personnel worked this case to
arrest
this crime has nevertheless left a mark
on our University our community and our
state
while we cannot bring back Maddie Kaylee
zaina and Ethan we can thoughtfully and
purposefully carry their legacy forward
in the work that we do
our students come first
and that was proven each and every day
of this investigation
we are committed to safely delivering
the college town atmosphere
campus experience
and high touch quality education for
which the University of Idaho is known
with time we will heal
we will move forward together
and we will remain Vandal strong with
that I'd like to turn it back over to
Chief Frye
so now we will open the floor to
questions however I want to remind
everyone as prosecutor Bill Thompson
explained any factual information
regarding the arrest of coal Burger is
currently sealed per Idaho law and will
not be released until he has appeared in
an Idaho Court
please formulate your questions
accordingly I recognize there are a lot
of questions and I will try to answer as
many of them as I can
Lauren Patterson Northwest public
broadcasting Spokane Public Radio I
realize the records are sealed I guess
I'm not too familiar with how it works
but can you tell us what tip what lead
what piece of evidence really LED you
all the way from Idaho to the suspect in
Pennsylvania
as I've said in the past that's part of
our investigation and we won't be
releasing that this time we we will have
those answers we'll have them as soon as
we can make those available to you then
a quick follow-up and a two-parter is
our community safe or is law enforcement
still on the search for other suspects
who might be involved in this attack
what I can tell you is we have a
individual in custody who committed
these horrible crimes and I do believe
our community is safe but we still need
to be vigilant right we still have
talked about this in the past we always
need to be aware of our surroundings and
make sure that we're aware of what's
going on
foreign
hi Chief how soon into the investigation
did police and law enforcement begin to
spot Mr coburger as a potential suspect
and a follow-up how many tips if you can
say were specifically related to Mr
coburger
to the tip part honestly I can't answer
that question so I'm not even going to
speculate on that on the other part
that's part of our investigation and it
will come out I'd like the mike to
please come right over here
thank you Dana Griffin with NBC News can
you confirm that Cole Burger asked
whether or not anyone else had been
arrested when he was in custody I cannot
confirm that or I'm not sure
um of that information but that would
still be a part of our investigation did
CODIS initially return any hits on this
guy
that's still part of our investigation
and that will come out if we could get
somebody over here please and then one
final question is there any message to
the online sleuths who slandered and
harassed people who they believed were
responsible
there was a lot of speculation going on
and we've always said from the very
beginning that we're the official
message that comes out and to pay
attention to what we're putting out
there to the Press
I'm Nancy Liu with news nation and we
were over at the house this morning and
you told us that the remediation would
begin today it was suddenly stopped can
you tell us why yes the house cleanup
has been halted and that came by a legal
request from the court
Christina Corbin Fox News Chief have you
identified a motive as part of the
investigation and that will come out as
we continue the investigation but what
we still ask is is for people to
continually send us things in the tip
line we are still looking for more
information we're still trying to build
that picture just like we have stated
all along we're putting all the pieces
together and that will help
Chief Veronica Miracle with CNN any
indication that the suspect knew the
victims that's part of the investigation
as well it won't be something that will
come out at this point in time but as we
continue the investigation and as this
case goes to trial that will be brought
forth have you spoken to the families
can you tell us what uh they've they've
told you today
are you talking the victims families
yeah we have reached out to the victims
family as we always do and we've done
that daily and we've continued to have
contact with them
hey Nate Sanford um you mentioned
earlier that you're still seeing tips
about Brian and the people should still
share whatever information they have can
you speak it all about what specifically
people should be reaching out for like
if they know something
I would say anything and everything as
we've said all along we we know what
tips we're looking for we will take
those tips and we will have
professionals look at those and decide
which pieces of those we need to use for
our case so um we ask that everybody
would do that
Angela Palermo Idaho Statesman
um your department and other
investigators on the case took a lot of
flag for keeping information close to
your chest are you glad that you did
that and were you worried about tipping
the suspect off I will 100 stand behind
the way that we handled this
investigation and this all started from
day one with our Patrol officers
arriving on scene locking down the scene
us calling in the Idaho State Police us
calling in the FBI and and keeping
information that was pertinent to this
case very very tight we want to have a
situation where when this goes to trial
there is no doubt that we've done
everything right and we've slowed down
and we've continued to slow down we'll
continue to do that
hey chief um have you guys found the
murder weapon or the uh Hyundai Elantra
so we are still looking for
um all pieces of evidence
um but we are still looking for the the
weapon
um and I will say that uh we have found
analotra
Stephanie Becker with CNN can you tell
what it was like when you got the phone
call when the police told you that
they had your suspect
I can tell you for a lot of law
enforcement it was a fairly Sleepless
couple of days with as we were leading
up to everything that we were doing but
what I can tell you is I have faith in
those agencies Across the Nation I have
faith in our officers I have faith in
the FBI and they did a great job but
sure there was uh sometimes even
throughout the day that we were always
concerned
hi Chief Don you're back at CBS News can
you talk a little bit more about the
suspect's connection to Pennsylvania
all I know is is that he lives in in
Pennsylvania
from non-stop local KHQ in Spokane more
about the Elantra we saw reports that
you mentioned that you were covered in
Elantra but can you specify where that
was found and we know that that was one
of the biggest pieces of information
you're asking from the public to tip
were you able to provide an information
on whether those tips led to this
seizure of an Elantra that's still part
of the investigation that will come out
in the future
Chief Glenn Mosley Idaho public radio
here in Moscow the additional police
presence in town and on campus semesters
coming is that going to continue
um you will continue to see state
troopers in the area you know we're
talking to latak County as well you will
see a presence of us that we're always
have up on campus we have assigned
officers to that so you will continue to
see a beloved person of presence
foreign
s
hi Chief Julie Scott ABC News um can you
tell us if you eventually had a license
plate number to the Elantra and how you
tracked it to Pullman
still part of the investigation that
will come out
Chief hi Matt Loveless with the Merle
College of communication I want to ask
about Mr coburger as a graduate student
at WSU are you aware of if you returned
to campus after November 13th and have
you had any communication with
departments on the WSU campus about his
attendance
so some of that is going to be followed
up as we continue our investigation
We'll be asking some of those questions
but that'll come out in the near future
so what I do want to do is I want to
thank you all you really have been the
national voice for us you've given us
the opportunity to get many many tips
and and I do appreciate everything
you've done and we'll continue to look
forward to working with you in the
future on this so I'd like to thank you
for that and thank you for your time
jurors